francesca au bout j'écoute alors moi ce
que je voulais dire à mathieu je les dis
déjà sur le plateau franchement il m'a
fait craquer pour plein de raisons mais
la première est la principale raison
c'est par sa sensibilité
j'ai un peu malencontreusement parfois
écouter ces conversations et voilà c'est
un être qui est ultra sensible et comme
je suis aussi
ça m'a vraiment touché et voilà je sais
que c'est pas je m'attaque pas un
dossier facile
non mais mais voilà j'avais besoin de
dire je pensais pas que ça allait
prendre d'aussi grandes proportions
parce que je voulais avait du mal me
connaître
mais mais voilà c'est totalement assumé
parce que je pense que dans la vie
canton sont des trucs faut les dire ça
sert à rien de tout garder pour soi et
puis voilà pourquoi pas il ya toujours
de l'espoir alors francesca je vous pose
la question qu'on pense que tous les
téléspectateurs m'oppose à chaque fois
que voilà que je suis tranquillement ou
en train de faire les courses ou bien
voilà en train d'acheter du salami chez
le boucher
les gens me disent c'est ce qu'elle n'a
pas fait ça pour le buzz ah oui c'est
une bonne question
non mais sérieux tout le monde me dit ça
tout le monde me dit oui comme elle
vient d'arriver dans l'équipe et qu'elle
est et qu'elle est nouvelle elle a
besoin de trouver sa place donc
peut-être qu'elle s'est dit l
intelligent da s'est dit tiens je vais
faire un buzz comme ça et dire que je
suis amoureuse de matthieu delormeau se
seraient pas bien ça vous m'entendez
c'est une question vous ne vendez pas
français je pense qu'on peut pas rigoler
sur ces choses là alors moi aussi on m'a
posé la question
c'est enfin pour moi ce serait se serait
hyper malsain et c'est pas mon truc moi
je suis quelqu'un de vrai j'ai dit ce
que je pensais
comme je vous dis je pensais pas que ça
prendrait d'aussi grandes proportions
mais voilà je suis sincère dans mes
sentiments donc qu'est ce que vous avez
à lui dire ce soir on résumer parce que
après mathieu je vous proposerai deux
choses
ouais et vous dirai quelle solution vous
allez choisir je lui dis ce que voilà
que je ressent des choses pour lui que
je tiens beaucoup à lui j'ai pas je
m'attends pas à ce que
il se révèle différent de ce qu'il était
avant mais voilà j'avais besoin de lui
dire mes sentiments mais finalement je
m'attends à rien je m'attende ça peut
être que du bon en fait mais vous voulez
vous avez envie de vivre une histoire
avec lui bah dont l'idéal oui bah je
suis pas oui humaine alors mathieu on le
sait comme ça a priori est ce qu est ce
qu elle m'offre quelque chose ce qu'elle
veut m'offrir quelque chose pour
vraiment être là c'est pas beau
non franchement ça c'est pas beau parce
que non non là c'est pas beau le scoop
avec moi sur le gang des lyonnais ce cas
elle est vraiment honnête elle et elle
elle a vraiment quelque chose pour toi
bon non non non non non calme non
franchement c'est pas toi tu vois c'est
parce qu'elle aime de toi je rigole
pascal heymes donné je rigole parce que
tu me connais un petit peu à froid et
que je préfère vous cueillir à froid
passer du canton bouteille à chaud on
risque d'avoir des problèmes alors
mathieu mathieu c'est très simple oui tu
vas donner ta réponse est à la fin de ta
réponse qui aura deux solutions ou tu me
dis je fais le slot de l'amour avec
francesca oui on ouvrira la scène où est
tu feras le slow d'amour avec elle et ça
veut dire que tu laisses peut-être la
porte et tous libres entrouvert est une
image l'autre du houblon ou bien tu me
dis non non ça ne se fera jamais c'est
complètement fermée
je suis sur complètement autre chose et
mathieu tu n'as jamais caché que voilà
francesca la basse
c'est ce n'était pas ton délire c 'est
pas francesco non mais qu'est ce que
t'es con mais non mais oui c'est oui ou
non mais non mais voilà mais attends
voilà mais tu tombes et toi tu es ouvert
à toute proposition
oui oui oui
non mais si oui alors je vais te dire
alors jeté la vérité pourquoi total on
était très ému quand j'ai écouté la
chanson mais tout ça en plus du fait que
c'est vrai en ce moment c'est pas la
meilleure période mais parce que si je
suis très honnête
au delà de toutes les vannes oc on fait
tout le temps dans cette émission et on
sort en boîte de nuit et plan cul et
plans q les plans cul en vrai de vrai je
trouve ça extrêmement touchant parce que
la dernière personne qui m'a dit des
mots si gentil ou ou même je t'aime
ça fait un petit moment que ce n'est pas
arrivé donc donc c'est très très
touchant quand une personne vous dit des
choses gentilles et sincère je sens
parfaitement qu'elle est sincère
voilà après je te ferai francesca les
les mots de dave que j'adore et qui
disait on ne tombe pas amoureux d'un
garçon d'une femme en tombe amoureux de
l'amour
donc je ne je ne te connais pas je te
trouve extrêmement jolie charmante je ne
te connais pas ça fait effectivement
très très longtemps que j'ai pas en tout
cas fait quelque chose avec une fille ça
fait combien de temps en tout cas je
pourrais vous dire que ça fait c'est
comme si pour vous donner une image ça
faisait oui à peu près 20 ans que je
conduis une voiture automatique et tout
d'un coup je repasse à une manuelle
j'ai peur de calais la voilà c'est plus
le contraire
ça fait la dernière fois que j'ai que
j'ai ressenti quelque chose pour une
fille où j'ai vécu quelque chose avec
une fille où j'avais 25 ans j'en ai 44
vous me dites oui je laisse la porte
grande ouverte pour la personne 30 chez
ce cas ou bien vous me dites non je ne
fais pas ce slot de l'amour car il ne se
passera jamais rien entre elle et moi à
la reprendre c'est ce qu'à ce qu'on peut
avoir francesca s'il vous plaît merci de
chèques c'est toujours beaucoup plus
facile d'ouvrir sa braguette que
d'ouvrir son coeur c'est de qui ça dit
qu'on leur côté de moi c'est évidemment
extrêmement touchant ce que tu as dit
vraiment bouleversé c'est très très très
touchant je te connais pas bien si tu es
très joli c'est tout ce que j'ai vu
jusqu'à maintenant et avec un vrai
caractère
donc je connais une phrase je connais
pas 50 comme disait marivaux en amour
laissons la vie décidée car c'est elle
qui décide
ja rule auclair qui disait en amour il
faut toujours un perdant
absolument et eu la chance de gagner
souvent web on s'en fou de rap et
mathieu alors c'est ce que je peux juste
te dire c'est que voilà c'est que c'est
que c'est touchant je te sent sincère et
que et que et que je laisse la porte
entrouverte c'est à dire que je serai
ravi de te rencontrer de te voir deux de
passer du temps avec toi de dîner avec
toi et ensuite je et ensuite la vie
décidera du tout si ça sera
effectivement une sorte d'amitié
amoureuse et qu'on sera très heureux
d'être ensemble et qu'en réalité on
n'aura pas besoin d'aller plus loin dans
ce qu'on sortira qu'on est très proche
et que et que et qu'on partage beaucoup
de choses
ou est-ce qu'au contraire je je je je
sais pas ce qui est sûr c'est ce que ce
soit avec toi
kelly que j'avais rencontré un petit
moment en ce moment c'est vrai que je
suis très touchée par peut-être la
douceur la gentillesse des défis et
peut-être que certaines choses que des
garçons ne peut
depuis ma portée je ne sais pas en tout
cas je je je je ne te promets rien mais
j'ouvre le rideau
[Applaudissements]
ils ont donc la demande
[Musique]
alors les chéris
les douze ans pour tous les deux à dîner
gastronomique de luxe dans un bateau
parisien le numéro 1 des croisières sur
la seine vous allez manger des dîners
ensemble la semaine prochaine c'est pour
moi c'est 4
[Applaudissements]